would your biggest regret in the way you
set up or organized or structured the
company I wish I wouldn't have raised
money and I would have just owned it all
and why is that cuz I would be greedier
and richer you didn't end up needing
that capital it's hard to say because it
worked it worked if I wanted to start
fresh again I would have been able to do
it I can start now
what about advice a lot of people think
oh this person is so successful right
you raise money from a bunch of cool
smart successful people either in media
or not in media yeah so that was helpful
was that truly like so did you get your
sort of values worth on the advice
component yes I'm not sure that that
typically plays out that way but I think
it works okay so look our network is so
powerful me and you our network
is so powerful I have I think 35
investors ranging from Tim Ferriss the
founders of nerd wallet which is who
knows what that's worth billions of
dollars the founder of the Chive
founders a bleacher report who else
just look it up a lot of people and I
text them I just braixen I'll say you
get a lot out of it I'll tell you two
things that you do that gets a lot first
your investor updates what you send
usually saying more frequently now I
said quarterly but before I for monthly
right 36 months I send up every single
month every single month and the it was
so well organized it was basically like
hey here's all the key metrics you don't
beat around the bush it's like this how
much cash we got in the bank this how
much we made this month there's how much
the email list grew this is how much our
open rate was boom that's number one
number two and how was your second sort
of the way that I set up as I go numbers
I go just here's the numbers there's no
interpretation right what all right
let's get into it numbers boom okay then
I go and then I do things that are going
well things are not going well I need
your help
yeah yes or no yeah it was great and you
sent that too so you did the work to
keep them engaged and stay top of mind
do not under under underestimate this if
you're doing your business if there's
people who are willing to help you out
you got to find a way to stay top of
mind and and part of it is you you share
frequent updates and there's a very good
sign if you're an investor if you're one
of your companies stop sending their
updates
that company's about to die or they're
on their way to dying and they go into a
shell and Paul Graham has this great
post which is just like as an investor
when you see that you know it's time to
go check in and as a founder ironically
that's when you need to help the most
yep so don't go quiet when you need the
help the most that's when you need to be
talking and asking and maybe you
actually won't die if you if you could
keep that going what other mistakes have
we made so I always regretted the I
think that the the normal way that
people give out equity is a little too
founder greedy so I wish I given more
equity to my team and so like you know
basically I wish I just negotiated it
better between what do I get what are
the investors get and what does my team
get I think it was imbalanced I think
some of what the investors got the team
should have got some of what I had the
team should have got because really like
the people who are there as person four
or five six really they're taken just as
much risk as you are in a way like they
were there when it wasn't obvious that
this was gonna work and so for the
all-stars I wish I had given more and
next time my next company I'll do just
that I will do you make sure that core
four core five people I'll make sure
it's not like like typically anaconda in
the pool be so I don't know exactly what
the pool will be but let's say let's go
what's typical so typical company
eighteen two co-founders you start 50/50
you're gonna raise some money they might
end up taking 25 to 30 percent of the
company depending on how it goes let's
call it 25 percent and so you know as
the founders you you've diluted down
your rat I don't know my maths bad but
let's say you're both at what is that 30
something of 35 percent each now and and
so you you know that's where you're at
and then your team the option pool they
typically say is like 10 to 15% is your
sort of option pool yeah so the first
few employees might have like you know
the key person might get like one to
three percent and then everybody else is
below that is below one percent
essentially and I just think that's like
a pretty hard skew so I would try to get
multiple people in these sort of one one
to four percent range I would try to
have like my core my core team all be in
the over one percent range for sure and
whether that means I take the haircut or
investors take the haircut
that's what I would do if it's a tech
company I think this is very different
if you're not a high-growth tech company
if you're in San Francisco again though
I'd started wherever I live and so if
I'm if I'm wanting to live here yeah I
started here if I wanted to live
somewhere else I started somewhere else
so now you can start it definitely
anywhere so it's just about your
preferences I if I was gonna start again
another thing that I would do is I would
go and get a job somewhere and just make
like when I started I hadn't I didn't I
was always self-employed mostly I wish I
would have worked somewhere made for a
little while before you did it or you
mean as I do something as a side hustle
before you just get the experience yeah
I think it would've been nice and it
saved money that's interesting I
wouldn't have thought you'd say that I
think it would be helpful to understand
how things I think if you did it for
three months you'd be like okay I'm done
it would have got it money away
[Music]
you